Brazilian president Lula da Silva had
hoped for strong commitments from his
peers to join his goal of zero
deforestation in the Amazon by the end
of this decade
had to settle for an agreement to revive
the dormant Amazonian nation's treaty to
save the world's largest rainforest from
ruin
we want to rekindle cooperation between
our countries and overcome suspicions we
will establish in the city of manaus an
international police cooperation Center
to confront the crimes impacting the
region
he's referring to the escalation of
organized crime throughout the poorest
Amazon region where drug trafficking and
illegal golden Emerald mining are
contaminating rivers and poisoning
indigenous communities
there was agreement to push for massive
International funding to transform the
economic structure of the giant
rainforest so that millions of poor
indigenous and non-indigenous
inhabitants can live in a sustainable
way but the big elephant in the room was
the thorny issue of oil extraction in
the Amazon region major oil producing
countries like Venezuela Bolivia Ecuador
and Brazil tried to avoid the subject
altogether but were energetically
chastised by Colombia's president
Gustavo petross
Petra said that politicians are being
held hostage to the fossil fuel industry
and warned that continuing to produce it
will destroy Humanity in decades not
centuries if we are on the edge of
Extinction we need a life saver and it's
in this decade that we as politicians
need to make the hard decisions
especially given our short mandates so
what are we doing just making speeches
like we're doing now
indigenous leaders in Environmental say
oil contamination destroys everything in
its path including the livelihood of
local communities critics say the final
document was full of good intentions but
short on deadlines it's better than
nothing but it falls far far behind of
what the region needs and of what the
planet needs right now really
nevertheless there did seem to be a
greater sense of urgency among the eight
Amazonian Nation leaders deforestation
of the world's largest rainforest has
already reached 17 percent and according
to scientists The Tipping Point is
almost here
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera belem Brazil
foreign